- [Woman] The era from 1945 to 1980
was action packed, to say the least.
During this period, the
United States experienced
the baby boom, the Civil Rights Movement,
the tumultuous 1960s, and
the quagmire of Vietnam.
This era was also riddled
with contradictions.
A sense of optimism in the
future and a conviction
that American economic
prosperity was endless
was tempered by fears
of nuclear annihilation
and a war on poverty.
A foreign policy based on democracy
and anti-communism, abroad,
was undermined by the
suppression of civil rights
and civil liberties, at home.
Material comforts and
Leave It To Beaver visions
of suburbia clashed with growing calls
for young people to tune
in, turn on, and drop out.
Would the generation
that fought World War II
even recognize the generation
that protested Vietnam?
That's the question I'd like
to explore, in this video,
taking a high-level look at the impact
the events of the postwar era
had on reshaping American
national identity.
How much did American
national identity change,
and how much did it stay the
same, over this time period?
To answer this question,
first, we have to define
what we mean by American
national identity.
In other videos, we've
looked at a few aspects
of American identity as
core ideological beliefs
about things like who
counts as an American,
whether the United States is exceptional,
or whether it's possible
for anyone to succeed,
so long as they work hard enough.
So if we're trying to
track continuity and change
in American identity, over
the period from 1945 to 1980,
what might be a few beliefs
we should trace, over time?
I encourage you to pause the video
and see if you can come up with a couple,
based on your knowledge of the
events in this time period.
Some big events that jump
out to me are the Cold War
and the Civil Rights Movement,
as well as the protests of the 1960s.
So with that in mind, the core beliefs
I'd like to look at are ideas
about the United States' role
in the world, who counts
as an American citizen,
and the country's cultural values.
You might have come up with
a totally different set of
beliefs, which is great.
Try out this same process
I'm about to model,
using the beliefs that you've chosen.
Now that we've got a few
aspects of national identity
we wanna track, let's compare each of them
at the beginning of this period
to the end of this period.
Remember, we're doing a super,
high-level overview, here.
So I'm not gonna take a whole lot of time
to explain events in detail.
But if something comes up
that you're unfamiliar with,
just make a note, and you can look it up
when you've got time.
All right, let's see what
changed and what stayed the same,
over this period, in beliefs about
the United States' role in the world.
In 1945, the United States
emerged as a world superpower,
having abandoned isolationism
as a foreign policy.
Instead, the United States
became a leading member
of the United Nations and
the NATO defensive pact.
The U.S. government was determined
to contain the spread of communism
and the influence of the Soviet Union
through providing military
and financial support
to nations fighting communism,
which would lead to American
military engagements
in Korea and Vietnam.
The United States also
had a lot of confidence
in its economic role in the world
as the only country whose industrial might
hadn't been compromised
by World War II bombings.
Immediately after the
war, the United States
was the world's leading
exporter of steel, cars,
consumer goods, and oil.
How does that compare to beliefs
about America's proper
role in the world in 1980?
Well, the United States was
still a world superpower
at the end of this era.
And it was still pursuing anti-communism
as a foreign policy.
But in the 1970s, the Cold War
entered a period of detente,
a relaxation of tensions
and increase in cooperation
between the United States
and the Soviet Union.
You could see this as the U.S. government
accepting peaceful coexistence
with the Soviet Union.
This approach will
change when Ronald Reagan
comes into office in 1981.
But the period of detente lasted
until the end of the 1970s.
The Vietnam War shook American confidence
in its interventionist foreign policy.
After the war, there was more reluctance
to commit U.S. troops, abroad,
in what's been called Vietnam Syndrome.
Likewise, the Nixon Doctrine
called for U.S. allies
to take primary responsibility
for their own defense.
Lastly, U.S. economic world
dominance was threatened,
in the late 1970s, as well,
as Japanese and German automobile makers
began competing internationally.
And the energy-dependent United States
found that its energy needs
were increasingly tied
to the oil exporting
countries of the Middle East.
So in terms of what changed
and what stayed the same,
from the beginning to the
end of the postwar era,
I would say that although
the United States
remained a world superpower,
committed to supporting
its allies and opposing
the spread of communism,
by the end of the 1970s, the
country looked to establish
some limits to its
intervention in world affairs.
Next, let's look at how
beliefs about citizenship
changed during this period.
After the shared experience
of G.I.s in World War II,
European immigrants who
had been looked upon
as dangerous others,
in the 1920s and 1930s,
were accepted as U.S. citizens
and categorized as simply white,
not Polish or Irish or Russian.
But African American soldiers,
who had served in segregated
units during the war,
weren't afforded the same courtesy.
Despite Truman's executive
order desegregating the military
in 1948, black veterans
encountered racial discrimination
after the war, along
with difficulty accessing
the government subsidies
for education and home loans
that white G.I.s took advantage of.
The immigration restrictions that set
national origin quotas in the 1920s
were still largely intact,
although the Chinese Exclusion
Act had been repealed
during the war as China was a U.S. ally.
Chinese Americans were then eligible
to become U.S. citizens.
However, the new quota
for Chinese immigrants
was just 105 individuals per year.
What were the beliefs around citizenship
at the end of the postwar era?
A lot changed during this time period,
thanks to the Civil Rights
Movement, Supreme Court decisions
like Brown versus Board of Education,
and legislation like the
the Civil Rights Act of 1964
and the Voting Rights Act of 1965.
At the end of the '60s,
African Americans were able
to access more citizenship rights
than they ever had, before.
And, in 1965, Congress repealed the old
national origin quotas and
passed new immigration laws,
allowing Asians to enter the country
as well as prioritizing
family reunification
and the entrance of skilled immigrants.
But in the late 1960s and 1970s,
there was a backlash against
the civil rights policies
set by the Supreme Court, in
the Johnson administration.
With many conservatives arguing
that the federal intervention
to advance civil rights
had gone too far, and with
some left-leaning organizations
arguing that it hadn't gone far enough,
to address issues like housing
and job discrimination,
looking at the changes and continuities
in beliefs about citizenship
over this period,
I'd say there was an enormous
expansion, over time,
in who was considered a citizen
or eligible to become a
citizen of the United States.
But there was also a growing antagonism
toward the federal government intervening
on behalf of civil rights.
Last, let's look at
American cultural values,
at the beginning and
end of the postwar era.
In the years after the war,
there was an emphasis on
domesticity and family life.
And women were expected to
give up their war time jobs
and seek fulfillment through
motherhood and consumption.
The United States began
a postwar economic boom
that looked virtually unstoppable.
In fact, the American
standard of living doubled
in the 25 years after World War II.
There was also a lot of pressure
for Americans to conform to
a homogenous, mass culture,
idealizing the white,
suburban, nuclear family.
Fear of communist infiltrators
led to witch hunts, like McCarthyism.
But few people people
questioned the wisdom
of the U.S. government or
authority figures, in general.
Compare that to the end of this period,
after the tumult of the 1960s
had turned American culture on its head.
In the 1960s and 1970s,
the sexual revolution
and women's rights movement challenged
the idealized, nuclear family,
allowing for a more
permissive sexual culture
and the advancement of
women in jobs and education.
Starting as early as the 1950s,
the Beat Generation began
to question the emptiness
of the single-minded pursuit of wealth
that was the American Dream.
In the 1960s, students
began to protest the draft
and the military industrial
complex, more generally,
wondering what the United States
was even doing in Vietnam.
They vowed not to trust anyone over 30.
By the 1970s, public confidence
in the U.S. government
was also at an all-time low,
after revelations about
presidential misdeeds
exposed by the Pentagon Papers
and the Watergate scandal.
To add insult to injury,
the endless economic boom
finally seemed to be at
an end, by the 1970s,
with deindustrialization and stagflation,
increasing prices and unemployment.
So it seems like American cultural values
changed a great deal, from 1945 to 1980,
from a culture of suburban conformity
to one of greater personal freedom
but also greater cynicism.
But it is important to note
that the people of the United States
didn't fully reject the
premise of the American Dream.
Despite the counterculture of the 1960s,
by the 1970s, most
people were still looking
for a good job and hoping
to buy a nice home.
If we return to our question, then,
how much did the events of the postwar era
reshape American identity?
I think we can respond that
they reshaped it quite a bit.
The Civil Rights
Movement, the Vietnam War,
and the protest movements of the 1960s
led to a U.S. national identity
that was considerably more
inclusive and socially free,
but also a good deal less confident
about its government or
its role in the world.
To see how these forces played out,
in the next stage of U.S. history,
we'll have to look to the 1980s.